president biden took his campaign for
his broad infrastructure plan to
philadelphia on friday
at the city's amtrak station mr biden
touted the good paying jobs and economic
opportunities
that come with his 2.3 trillion dollar
proposal
but he wants republican backing for this
plan and he makes it clear he will not
accept
anything smaller christina raffini has
more for us from the white house good
morning christina
good morning you know the president
joked that he used to only end up in
philly if he fell asleep on the train
and missed his stop in wilmington
but yesterday he was there to mark
amtrak's 50th anniversary
and try to get the country all aboard
his infrastructure plan
as i've said from the beginning when i
think about fighting climate change i
think about jobs
standing at philadelphia's 30th street
station
president biden argued that
eco-conscious infrastructure
could power america's economic engine
we have a once-in-a-generation
opportunity position amtrak
and rail play a central role in our
transformation and transportation
economic future
the president is proposing two trillion
dollars of torque
a sweeping infrastructure plan that
includes upgrading twenty thousand miles
of roads
ten thousand bridges and provides eighty
billion dollars for improving passenger
rail and freight trains
good transit equals vibrant communities
it is an
investment in job creation it is an
investment increasing access to
opportunity
vice president kamala harris visited
cincinnati on friday
part of an all-out administration effort
to convince working americans they will
benefit from the bill
a recent cbs news ugov poll shows most
americans are generally supportive of
improvements to infrastructure
even measures that go beyond the
traditional definition
like providing home care for the elderly
and boosting the nation's broadband
there's good ideas in there but they
should be considered as
ideas that are not infrastructure but
republicans argue the bill is too broad
and too expensive
they want the white house to negotiate
with them on a compromise
one that does not include raising taxes
on the wealthiest americans
to pay for all those fixes the president
is proposing
they need the votes they'll come talk to
us and we'll see how much they will
actually listen
the president invited west virginia
senator shelly moore capito to the white
house she's leading republican
negotiations on the bill
yesterday she tweeted a picture of
herself on the phone with the president
writing we both expressed our mutual
desire to work together
and deliver results for the american
people so we'll have to see if they can
get those negotiations
chugging along oh dana
but i feel like i have to at least give
you that christina
it's it's early it's infrastructure come
on guys i got to make sure you're paying
attention
we are we appreciate it christina thank
you